If you were looking to get your heart melted today,
well, we've got you covered.
Fox News reports a second grade class
at St. Michael's School in Richmond, Virginia,
is learning about persuasive writing.
And to practice, they're writing adopt me letters
for local dogs at the shelter.
Each student was assigned a dog
and then briefed on their personality.
And then they wrote letters from the dogs
asking to be adopted.
Here's a sample.
Hello, I'm Potato Chip, I'm a Pit Bull.
I won't hurt you, I'll give you lots of kisses, slurp.
I like the animal shelter, but I wanna live with you.
Oh, come on.
They wrote letters for 24 dogs and one cat,
and so far, now eight pets have found their forever home.
(audience applauds)
This one gets me.
I know.
I mean, is this not like a potential new model too,
because we're looking,
you know, I'm a huge advocate for animal rescue.
Me too.
And this would be such a game changer,
it's such a heartbreaking process,
and kids get to learn empathy and writing skills,
and the customers who are out there searching
get a little sense of the animals.
It could really change the whole experience.
I mean, eight adoptions,
like you could double the game here.
You're so right.
This is a model that should be in schools across the country
because it teaches not only the writing skills,
but empathy, cause and effect,
how you can make a difference.
These little kids are doing this, it's incredible.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I even...
And it helps with when you're adopting
to get a little insight into that animal.
Yeah, you know, my Wellington is in charge
of curriculum at a school, a district in Long Island.
I sent this to him.
I'm like, now I don't tell you what to do,
'cause you know what you're doing, but you gotta do this,
'cause this is so,
it just moved me so much.
It moves me so much.
Well, let's see what he does with this
and maybe a suggestion, if anybody wants to take it,
just keep this going, it's so wonderful.
Yes, please.
Thank you for doing that, you're an example to us all.
Let's keep this going.
(upbeat bright music)